[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 16 septembre très
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 voici les titres de ce journal
près de 300 pompiers des yvelines dans
la rue aujourd'hui ils ont démarré leur
mobilisation devant le château de
versailles avant de faire une halte au
conseil départemental est depuis le mois
de juin un mouvement de grève touche la
profession en raison du manque
d'effectifs est la confédération local
des petites et moyennes entreprises
tenez ces portes ouvertes aujourd'hui à
rambouillet l'occasion est de prendre le
pouls actuel de la santé économique sur
le territoire françois bayle ni premier
vice président de la cci versailles
yvelines sera en plateau et nous
parlerons justement avec lui de la
finale du challenge paris-saclay au
programme demain si start up sont en
lice à la clé pour les vainqueurs un
ticket direction le cs de las vegas en
janvier 2020 elle revient justement des
états unis la réalisatrice yvelinoise
jenna sur rue était dans le
massachussetts pour présenter son fils
lors d'un festival elle est notre invité
à suivre également du sport reprises
deux saisons handball pour les féminines
de montigny
[Musique]
ils étaient environ 300 rassemblés ce
matin devant le château de versailles
les sapeurs pompiers des yvelines ont
donné de la voix pour faire entendre
leur revendication est la retraite
recrudescence des appels et des
agressions mais surtout un manque
d'effectifs ont fait le point avec
mathilde et demi en tenue et armés de
leurs banderoles les sapeurs pompiers
des yvelines qui se sont donnés rendez
vous devant le château de versailles
les mots d'ordre faire du bruit et
montré la présence de pompiers dans les
riffs aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de
prendre rendez-vous auprès des instances
comme le conseil départemental et la rs
pour les problèmes en liaison avec le
samu 78 notamment afin de se faire
entendre sur les difficultés que
rencontrent sur le terrain
quotidiennement
[Applaudissements]
au son des gyrophares les pompiers se
rassemblent devant le conseil
départemental pour rencontrer une
délégation
une manifestation qui ne s'était pas
produit depuis 1999 et qui surprend les
passants j'ai vraiment manifestations et
je m'excite les pompiers et comme
on est solidaire avec eux quand même il
faut des choses bien quand même ils ont
raison de manifester sur des choses qui
ne m'ont pas john toll a besoin d'eux
que c'est qu'on appelle et pompiers ils
sont là ouais mais c'est fondamental
d'avoir une caserne de pompiers
ils rendent des services inimaginable
sauf qu'il faut qu'il soit un effectif
normal
à la sortie du conseil départemental les
représentants des syndicats annoncent 22
ans gauche en octobre et peut-être une
cinquantaine en début d'année prochaine
une déclaration qui nous va pas les
sapeurs qui on nous dit à chaque fois
qu'on embauche 10 15 20 30
sapeurs-pompiers enfin sauf qu'un a
autant qui partent d'année en année donc
a la final le bilan c'est toujours le
même on s'aperçoit que dans les centres
dans les services c'est toujours pareil
on court toujours après le personnel une
première manifestation qui montre que
les pompiers sont bien présents dans les
rues
le 15 octobre les pompiers viendront de
toute la france à paris pour exprimer
leur mécontentement dont l'actualité du
jour également franck riester à
versailles le ministre de la culture a
accueilli 200 élus au château de
versailles membres du réseau micro folie
des musées numérique léger et modulable
le gouvernement se fixe comme objectif
d'accélérer le dispositif est de
l'étendre notamment aux territoires où
l'accès à la culture est restreint le
mois de septembre c'est aussi la rentrée
pour les chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui
la cpam des yvelines a ouvert ses portes
l'occasion pour notre rédaction de faire
le point sur la santé économique des pme
du territoire on en parle avec vous
françois bellini bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le premier vice président de la cci
versailles yvelines la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et bonsoir
nicolas landry de la rédaction de tv 78
comment se portent nos entreprises en
cette rentrée 2010 neuf et bien grégory
globalement la situation économique des
pme chinoises étaient plutôt bonnes lés
ces chiffres vont dans ce sens le
premier concerne l'emploi
selon une étude du baromètre emploi
parisjob sur lesdits promis les six
premiers mois de l'année 2019 les
yvelines connaissent la plus forte
croissance d'offres d'emploi proposées
en ile de france une augmentation de 20%
durant ce premier semestre
autre donnée le nombre de créations
d'entreprises en 2018 près de 17000 300
sociétés ont vu le jour dans les îles
mais un petit rappel c'est au total le
département au compte plus de 95 mille
entreprises et à ce propos je vous
propose d'écouter le président de la
cpam des yvelines thomas godefroy scola
au micro de margaux du roi et rodolphe
blondel normalement les entreprises se
portent bien plutôt mieux qu'en 2018 ou
2010 est donc chaque année on sent une
amélioration évidemment il ya des
situations très difficiles il y à des
modifications de technologie de loi et
cetera qui en font disparaître certaines
mais je crois que 2019 c'est l'année où
on est le plus de créations
d'entreprises des dix dernières années
alors on voit un moral globalement bon
on note quand même différentes
situations dans en fonction des secteurs
d'activité un constat de jean marc le
blue qu il est dirigeant d'un groupe de
pme spécialisées dans le développement
commercial et la formation
professionnelle globalement j'ai pas
senti on va dire une superbe croissante
loppsi les indicateurs sont plutôt au
beau fixe on va dire ça comme ça on est
sur le terrain on ressent pas jeudi ans
et il faut se battre tous les jours ce
qui est normal mais mais on sent pas une
envolée lyrique dans le développement du
chiffre d'affaires et surtout dans le
fait que les entreprises aient confiance
dans l'avenir
aujourd'hui ont toutes les entreprises
ont des difficultés de trésorerie plus
plus vous êtes dans un dans un second
appel un développement fort de
l'attractivité ce qui est notre cas la
plus il faut trouver des sources de
financement car aujourd'hui trouver des
sources de financement sont pas les
banques parce qu'elle ne va pas me
prêter donc il ya 10 à cette forme
aujourd'hui de difficultés en fait du
chef d'entreprise du financement de sa
croissance
or voilà différentes croissance en
fonction des secteurs d'activité et nous
avons rencontré aussi deux entreprises
qui connaissent une forte croissance une
dirigeante d'établissements d'accueil de
jeunes enfants et un directeur d'une pme
de services informatiques des métiers en
tension avec des difficultés à recruter
l'activité
2019 pour nous est plutôt est plutôt
bonne puisque la dynamique est là par
contre beaucoup de difficultés à
recruter des compétences en informatique
qui sont aujourd'hui des compétences
très recherchés donc voilà on a besoin
de pouvoir recruter des gens formés ou
immédiatement opérationnel
j'ai beaucoup embauché puisque j'ai créé
donc oui il ya eu des recrutements il y
en a eu pas mal et puis je recrute
également des c ap petite enfance par
alternance voilà donc je prends aussi
les apprentis parce que le secteur de la
petite enfance reste quand même un
secteur de turnover c'est quand même un
secteur où on voit l'aller on a des
jeunes donc il reste pas forcément on a
un turnover la part des jeunes qui vous
dit c'est bon un an j'ai fait le tour et
donc ils vont aller voir ailleurs et
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal de turnover
françois bellini si on fait un bilan on
voit que il ya beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
beaucoup de personnes se lancent dans
l'entrepreunariat beaucoup d'offres
d'emploi avec parfois dans certains
secteurs
pas de demande d'emploi en face et des
activités qui ont plus ou moins de
croissance quel constat quelle est la
situation économique vous de votre côté
quel regard vous portez à la cci alors
le bal mans les données économiques
soient assez paradoxal en fait sur l'île
de france
il ya des secteurs qui sont en
souffrance on peut penser au premier
trimestre 2010 9 le tourisme un petit
peu souffert sur l'île de france du fait
des manifestations notamment
mais il ya des secteurs qui ont bien
progressé la création d'emplois a
augmenté aussi bien soin de france qui
sur les yvelines les défaillances
d'entreprises ce qui est un point
important parce que de créer à côté il
faut que les entreprises perdure
défaillances d'entreprises s'est stoppée
au niveau des deux français a baissé au
niveau des yvelines en termes de taux de
chômage le taux de chômage en
ile-de-france est de l'ordre de 7 25%
sur les yvelines on est à 6,5
c'est à dire que c'est le meilleur taux
qu'il y ait sur toute l'île de france
donc en termes de chômage effectivement
on a des résultats qui sont positifs le
paradoxe c'est que les entreprises
recherchent des profils avec des
compétences nouvelles qui nous qu'on ne
trouve pas forcément et l'adéquation de
donc pas forcément avec les gens qui a
recherche de l'emploi nous ça veut dire
votre vision de premier vice-président
votre vision aussi d'entrepreneurs ce
que vous avez une entreprise
elle est globalement bonne cette vision
sur les yvelines en tout cas sur les
yvelines tous les chiffres sont couverts
il faut être honnête comme l'a dit tout
à l'heure une personne qui a été
interviewé ça veut pas dire que tout est
parfait
on a encore plein de choses à améliorer
notamment sur la recherche de personnel
avec des qualifications les formations
adaptées aux qualifications sont des
points importants restent tout de même à
un territoire attractif les yvelines oui
c'est clairement un territoire attractif
avec un nombre de créations
d'entreprises qui en forte progression
et des défaillances qui sont
relativement faibles aujourd'hui vous
organisé demain justement il faut pas
retenir la finale du challenge paris
saclay à la royale factory à versailles
si start-up finaliste pour un ticket
pour le cs de las vegas c'est justement
aussi pour montrer tout ce dynamisme
yvelinois ces jeunes entreprises qui se
créent que vous avez lancé ce ce
challenge tout à fait l'oral à la base
c'est parti d'un projet qui s'appelle
open innove qui est une plate forme
qu'on a mis en place à l'intention de
toutes les entreprises les start up
innovantes les systèmes de laboratoires
de recherche privé public et de mettre
en relation un petit peu tout le monde
en a on a créé ça il ya cinq ans il ya
quatre 4 ans on s'est dit que ce serait
bien d'aller un petit peu plus loin en
terme de challenge on va dire et on a
créé ce concours il ya quatre ans qui
consiste à demander à des start-up une
vingtaine de start up française
francilienne et surtout sur paris
s'attelait de montrer et d'expliquer un
petit peu leur leurs nouveaux produits
innovants dans le monde du numérique et
qui font moins de 8 ans au niveau de
l'entreprise et un jury composé des
différents partenaires de la chambre de
commerce vont sélection sélectionné six
entreprises
il y a deux gagnants en fait le premier
gagnant c'est le prix du jury qui sera
indiqué demain soir et le deuxième
gagnant parce que c'est un client à prix
du public qui sera présent demain soir
il
à l'issue de d'un pitch des ceinturons
devant le public choisira quelle est la
meilleure société
alors vous l'avez dit un challenge
depuis quatre ans forcément des lauréats
en novembre 2018 justement la société
anamnèse a remporté ce challenge
l'entreprise qui aide les médecins à
optimiser le parcours de son de leur
passion s'est donc envolé à las vegas
pour le cs le bilan un an après avec
mathilde de 2 min la petite start up de
paris saclay a bien grandi depuis sa
victoire à ap innove et son passage aux
crs de las vegas anamnèse l'assistant
virtuel des professionnels de santé se
développent et cherchant visibilité dans
le milieu médical et dans de potentiels
investisseurs
sitôt qu'on a gagné ce le goulot
concours on a pu beaucoup plus
communiquer sur un amenait je pense que
ça permet de cristalliser les les
besoins et les envies des investisseurs
d'investir chez nous on a pu réaliser
notre levée de fonds entre eux justement
novembre et janvier en 2018 charlotte
était stagiaire chez anamnèse grâce à la
victoire de la start up elle a pu se
faire embaucher par la suite en cdi une
évolution pour l'entreprise qui
accueille maintenant dix salariés et qui
s'attaque à de plus en plus de projets
le cf la maturité de la boîte aussi qui
avance au fur et à mesure les
différentes personnes qu on a pu
rencontrer tout ça a fait que oui la
boîte elle a vraiment les projets ont
changé les l'émission aussi sont de plus
en plus intéressantes et ça nous ouvre
des portes
un avenir prometteur pour un amener ce
qui a pour vocation d'améliorer la santé
de la population et de s'implanter
prochainement à l'étranger premièrement
être capable de de réduire les
inégalités de vis-à-vis de la ce que
chacun peut avoir vis-à-vis de la santé
deuxièmement on a une grande capacité je
pense qu'on a un très bon catalyseur
pour développer la téléconsultation
des innovations dans le domaine de la
santé qui vont peut-être révolutionner
la vie des médecins infirmiers et
patients on l'a vu au travers de ce
sujet françois bellini gagner ce
challenge s'envoler pour las vegas pour
ce salon qui est l'un des plus grands
événements si ce n'est le plus grand des
technologies et de l'innovation c'est
une réelle chance pour ces startups oui
oui c'est un vrai tremplin
ça on l'a vu d'ailleurs sûr j'ai fait un
retour sur l'année trois dernières
années 4 42 était un des compléments de
il était à 2,1 mds 4,42
entre temps ils ont gagné un grand prix
avec orange j'arrive à take her
l'énergie square a eu un des business
angels qui ont investi dans l'entreprise
et je reviens sur wii pull site il ya
deux ans quand inventer des gangs pour
des drones projet là des drones
ils sont à six salariés aujourd'hui et
wonder kraft qui a créé un exosquelette
à 60 salariés n'ont que ça change la
donne c'est un challenge madone et ça
fait du bien au niveau des emplois alors
demain vous l'avez dit six finalistes
qui aura un vainqueur du jury un
vainqueur du public
le profil on a des start-up vraiment sur
des secteurs diversifiés
il ya des secteurs complètement
différents les uns des autres certains
soient orientés sur l'optimisation de la
consommation d'énergie d'autres sont sur
l'écriteau menait donc il ya vraiment de
tout ce qui est intéressant c'est ces
deux entreprises qui vont aller à las
vegas ça va être pour eux un moyen de
faire connaître l'entreprise de faire
connaître leur leurs nouveaux produits
et on sait que il suffit d'un bon
contact
vous êtes des états unis des fois pour
attaquer un marché mondial le but du jeu
étant qu'ils puissent innover encore
plus est fabriqué ce qu'ils ont innové
et présenteront ils feront un pitch
demain devant le public sur leur start
up ça veut dire qu'il ya une préparation
avant cette soirée vous les avez
accompagné
les permanents de la chambre les ont
accompagnés évidemment essais organisés
avec un timing très serré avec avec un
jury professionnel de personnes
compétentes qui seront présents
puisqu'ils vont ils vont présenter leur
choix et vont expliquer pourquoi leur
choix et on fera voter enfin le jury
demain soir pour qui nous indique quelle
est la meilleure société finale du
challenge paris saclay crs las vegas
demain mardi à la royale factory à
versailles le lancement de la soirée est
prévue à es19 remercie françois berleand
est ressassé en plateau au premier vice
président de la cci versailles yvelines
se chiffre à présent 3 3 femme tuée sous
les coups de leur conjoint depuis le
début de l'année dans les yvelines élus
magistrats forces de l'ordre et
associations se sont réunis vendredi au
tribunal de grande instance à versailles
pour une réunion locale du grenelle des
violences conjugales l'objectif rappelé
les actions en cours en 2018 1626 à
procédure pour violences conjugales ont
été traités à deir sai axes
d'amélioration soulevées notamment
pendant la réunion améliorer la fluidité
des informations entre le parquet et les
juges ou encore réduire les délais de
convocation des prévenus devant le
tribunal
le grenelle à des violences conjugales
doit prendre fin en novembre fin fin
novembre seuls 20% des français
maîtrisent les gestes de premiers
secours la croix rouge des yvelines à
croix rouge française aussi organise des
formations et même une journée mondiale
de ses gestes qui sauvent des vies
l'événement au niveau national a élé a
été lancée à versailles samedi dernier
une première dans la cité royale
patrick jacques de dixmude et marylène
iapichino cette même un accident de
trottinette sur la voie publique et
présente un traumatisme
une équipe de la croix rouge intervient
pour pouvoir l'amener à l'hôpital dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
pas de blessés ceci n'est qu'un exercice
une démonstration pour aguerrir le
public on a si vous voulez des
protocoles et des procédures qui nous
permettent justement d'assurer l'état de
la victime surtout d'éviter toute
aggravation car notre rôle le premier
c'est d'assurer les premiers secours
mais surtout de la transporter dans de
meilleures conditions
donc c'est vrai que ça peut paraître un
peu procédurier mais c'est justement
pour les tables à bitche le
défibrillateur énormément d'endroits
publics fait indiquée par ce symbole
utilisation d'un défibrillateur
technique du massage cardiaque parfois
même en réalité virtuelle
toute la journée la croix-rouge organisé
des formations gratuites toutes ont été
complètes dont notre rôle d'auxiliaire
d'état c'est de former le grand public à
savoir quels gestes faire pour ce laps
de temps ce maillon de la chaîne de
l'urgence un événement qui s'adressait à
tous les publics de tous les âges pour
sensibiliser le plus de monde possible
si on sait ce qu'il faut faire ça va
très vite quoi ça peut permettre de
sauver quelqu'un plutôt que de rester à
côté ou de passer à côté il ya pas mal
je sais pas faire non c'est très utile
objectifs à atteindre pour la croix
rouge française
une personne formée aux gestes de
premiers secours par foyer une info
pratique après six mois de travaux le
centre des finances publiques à
guyancourt rouvre une offre de service
moderniser sera proposé à partir de
lundi prochain des ordinateurs en libre
service vous permettront de faire toutes
vos démarches en ligne un service de
paiement de vos impôts de vos amendes
sera également disponible sur place
uniquement en paiement par carte
bancaire à noter que désormais l'accueil
des usagers professionnels se fera
uniquement sur rendez-vous pour ce faire
allez sur le site impots.gouv.fr contact
vous pouvez aussi contacter le service
des impôts prendre directement rendez
vous un surplace au guichet c'est la
troisième résidence qui va sortir de
terre aux quarante arpents à maurepas
l'éco quartier de la ville inquiète en
cours de construction vendredi la
première pierre de ce programme de 2 163
logements a été symboliquement posée la
résidence bienville porté par le
promoteur prime arte se composera de six
bâtiments sur trois et quatre étages des
logements en accession à la propriété et
mais aussi des logements sociaux et
intermédiaires explications au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude 263 logement
répartie avec du logement en accession
pour 122 logements 94 logements sociaux
qui vient répondre à un besoin des
communes d'un quota de logements sociaux
avec des plans sur deux et trois ans et
on à complémenter 7 cette offre avec du
logement intermédiaire ici
hauts-de-seine habitat achète 47
logements locatifs intermédiaires non
pas sur la part sociale puisque certains
résidents ce qui fait la part sociale
nous on va les acheter des logements qui
va concerner les locataires qui sont
juste au dessus en fait des plafonds de
ressources du logement social sans
pouvoir aller sur le marché du libre des
jardins partagés un bassin de rétention
depuis des voies de circulations douces
ou encore une oeuvre d'art seront
aménagés au sein de ce programme de
logement le sport et ce résultat de
handball féminin vous proposez première
journée de nationale 2 et première
victoire pour nous de signer le
bretonneux samedi succès à domicile à 32
à 28 contre le paris saint-germain
pourtant le match avait mal commencé
pour les inhumant tel le résumé de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de nicolas
d'ombrie de la joie du soulagement pour
les handballeuses de montigny le
bretonneux pour leur premier match de la
saison elles se sont imposés 32 à 28
face au psg ce samedi 14 septembre au
gymnase pierre de coubertin
une rencontre mal débuté par les hymnes
ten début est difficile
dur de rentrer dedans après
c'est vrai que toute l'équipe a était
pas vraiment dedans mais on a réussi
quand même on va dire est resté soudé et
de faire une bonne deuxième mi-temps
quoi quand il a parlé dans un vestiaire
menés sur le score de 14 à 17 à la mi
temps brahim sadi nouvel entraîneur des
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
donne des consignes pour relancer son
équipe face à la ténacité des
parisiennes les yvelinoises réussissent
à prendre le score
elle ne le lâcheront pas jusqu'à la fin
de la partie en deuxième mi temps on a
essayé de
justement corriger ça aux vestiaires
donc on a demandé justement d'être plus
agressives en défense d'être plus
compact de travailler ensemble sur un
bloc
et c'est ce qui nous a réussi donc on a
eu aussi efficace et dire qu'on n'a pas
eues en première mi temps
nos objectifs déjà on est en train de
construire un groupe qui est solide on a
essayé devra on a eu des départs on a on
a dû recrues il faut que la mayonnaise
prenne donc on joue un match par match
un nouveau projet de jeu mis en place
par l'entraîneur avec la volonté d'avoir
une continuité dans le travail à
l'entraînement pour la deuxième journée
lésigny monteyne se déplace à
aulnay-sous-bois ce dimanche 22
septembre à 16 heures c'est un colosse
physique avec ses 2 m 0,4 et ses 130 kg
colosse du sport aussi teddy riner était
de passage dans les yvelines samedi
dernier
le judoka étaient présents pour une
opération commerciale dans une
concession automobile de mantes-la-ville
plusieurs enfants de clubs locaux ont pu
approcher le double médaillé olympique
et champion du monde à dix reprises
teddy riner qui a repris l'entraînement
ce lundi à l'insep après son forfait cet
été aux mondiaux à tokyo
cette information est bien d'autres
encore développé dans l'émission le
cetud sports présenté par nicolas landry
c'est à retrouver après ce journal sur
tv 78 mais avant justement de refermer
cette édition on invite est une jeune
réalisatrice de 27 ans originaire de
chevreuse et qui revient à tout juste
des états unis bonsoir d'une nature hu
pensera grégory alors vous êtes la
réalisatrice productrice et actrice dans
le long métrage l'âge d'or il a été
sélectionné au massachusetts indaba
donne film festival qui se tenait à
début septembre près de boston présenter
votre film en première mondiale en plus
aux états unis ce que c'était un rêve
pour vous un accomplissement peut être
énorme
c'était un vrai rêve parce que dès
l'écriture de ce film
l'âge d'or que j'ai aussi donc
effectivement écrit j'avais vraiment en
tête le besoin de passer ce message
l'âge d'or raconte l'histoire de ces
deux artistes dans les années 60 qui
rêvent de changer le monde et c'est un
message qui est vraiment est très
important aussi pour les générations
aujourd'hui ce rêve de changement
et depuis le départ dès que j'ai écrit
la toute première scène du film
eh bien j'avais en tête l'idée de
partager avec le public pour qu'ils
ressentent aussi être frustration et
cette envie de faire changer les choses
et aussi ce décor incroyable des années
60 avec le pari est le saint tropez
d'année 60 puisque c'est là où ils se
retrouvent et le partage et pour la
toute première fois on s'était déjà vu
au festival de
mais là c'était vraiment la première
mondiale donc la première fois qu'on
partagé la victoire avec le public et le
public notamment américains et c'était
vraiment un très très beau moment est
votre film a été sélectionné dans la
catégorie de la meilleure actrice du
meilleur acteur aussi alors pas de
récompense au final on imagine que
c'était on l'entend dans vos propos déjà
une victoire d'être présent sur place
oui oui c'est vraiment un très très beau
festival l'équipe faire un travail
absolument énorme pour pousser les
cinémas indépendants et encore une fois
en fait les retours après la projection
était vraiment excellent moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup touché c'est que ça a beaucoup
confirmé ce qui avait été dit pendant le
festival de cannes c'est que on m'a dit
que c'était vraiment impressionnant
comment j'avais réussi à saisir ce que
c'est qu'être une femme est aussi un
homme américain
à l'époque cette frustration par rapport
à la guerre puisque le personnage de
sebastian fui la guerre du vietnam et
angèle cette femme qui est actrice mais
à qui on demande pas d'être ambitieuse
qui journée toute petite salle de
théâtre et qui sait pas vraiment en fait
quelle place elle peut avoir dans cette
époque et ce en rencontrant sebastian à
paris en 67 qui lui fait prendre
conscience de comment elle peut vraiment
se libérer et aller beaucoup plus loin
et aller tout en haut des marches est
vraiment oui c'était ces deux
personnages qu'on aime beaucoup dans
cette atmosphère vraiment raide époque
on a tourné dans 35 exceptionnel près de
saint tropez à saint tropez à paris et
aussi aux états unis saint-tropez qui
joue un rôle clé dans ces années 60 ce
petit village de pêcheurs qui devient
grand qui accueille les artistes de
l'époque
c'est exactement ça en fait c'est ça
c'est vraiment la vraie star du film
parce que c'est une histoire qui n'a
jamais été racontée à l'écran
reconstitués comme cela le village de
saint tropez des années 60 avec toutes
ses vedettes qui allaient à l'époque
pour trouver l'inspiration mais qui
finalement été traité comme tout le
monde et c'était pour elle comme un
espèce de hub d'inspiration artistique
où il pouvait enfin trouvé l'inspiration
pour changer le monde ce qu'ils ont fait
et le chemin on s'est rencontrés par
mois accueil voilà où vous
fodié la distribution du film voilà vous
étiez là aussi pour rencontrer des
directeurs de festivals du coup c'est
directement lié vous avez pu nouer des
contacts et c'est pour ça que vous êtes
parti aux états unis vous avez pu nouer
des contacts sûrs c'est exactement ça
donc l'idée comme on l'avait dit à
cannes pendant le festival c'est de
rencontrer les festivals dans le monde
entier c'était le tout début et là ça se
concrétise desjardins aura plus des
festivals y aura vraiment des annonces
qui seront faites très bientôt
et donc c'est très très beau de voir que
déjà aussitôt ça fait même pas un an
qu'on a fini un peu plus d'un an qu'on a
fini le tournage on a à peine finie la
post production du film et le film est
déjà monté dans des très beaux festivals
donc c'est un très très beau début pour
la suite vu que la suite pour vous c'est
présente dans d'autres festivals parce
qu'il ya des dates déjà établis
exactement alors elles seront annoncés
très bientôt on est vraiment très très
fier des festivals déjà de cette
première mondiale et de la suite
le film a aussi été après cannes
présenté au marché de toronto où j'ai
fait un passager ou le film a reçu sa
première critique qui est excellente qui
vient tout juste de sortir d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux je les ai vu
tout à l'heure sur un média canadien
donc c'est une critique qui est vraiment
très très bonne et ce qui est très très
beau c'est que là pour le coup c'est un
média canadien
c'est vraiment un film à destination
internationale et eux aussi ils ont
vraiment accroché et se sont vraiment
identifié à ses personnages qui se
sentent pas à l'aise dans leur époque
donc c'est un très beau message d'espoir
on suit votre actualité aussi les
prochains projets pourquoi pas à suivre
avec votre société de production qui est
basée à chevreuse dans les yvelines
c'est belle époque film on peut suivre
ça tout ça sur votre site internet merci
janeiro exactement mais doit passer en
plateau réalisatrice productrice de ce
long métrage l'âge d'or voilà c'est la
fin de cette édition le cetud journal à
retrouver également sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
rendez vous demain pour une nouvelle
page d'actualités locales belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]